welcome back to new rock stars the thor
love and thunder trailer has us asking a
ton of questions but none of them are
more important than where the heck is
darcy i miss her it's been too long like
why has she not been prominently
featured in the promo materials okay she
wasn't thor too she needs to be in 4-4
has she been permanently altered by the
west view hex
is she a different person i hope not
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love and adore my name is
mt going rogue with me today is director
of activities on the new asgard cruise
line it's jessica clemens what's going
on jess
hi
no children under
12 allowed
and there might be nudity and there
might be nudity baby brandon is this fun
enough for you am i being fun enough
it's real scary now that's pretty fun
that's pretty fun
that's pretty dang fun um especially
because there's no kids allowed that's
that's when we can have all the fun
because kids are too loud just kidding i
don't hate kids
a little bit um and flying in on her
magic boat pulled by goats it's whitney
van landingham what's going on with me i
have a goat boat
yes we were gonna surprise you a couple
days from now but i i broke the news too
soon oh my god wait so it's gonna it's
gonna be like those honda commercials
where they like you know like the mom
goes outside on christmas morning and
there's like a honda wrapped in a bow on
her driveway it's gonna be that but a
goat boat for me
yeah exactly two golden bones on their
horns
basically i'm into it
and finally he hopes to one day be a
retired space viking it's off-screen
producer brandon what's going on brendan
how's your retirement dreams going oh
pretty good you know you got to grow
that pension every year you got to save
for retirement make sure you're you're
putting away a little bit of your
doubloons every paycheck so that you got
a sweet doubloons all those sweet
ravager doubloons you gotta say yeah
well guys in that thor love and thunder
trailer we saw some fancy new looks for
our heroes i mean i don't know if you
saw that big ass helmet on thor's face
um but uh that's that's definitely new
haven't seen thor the dogs
no
i've never been interested in a back
tattoo but as soon as i saw him wearing
it i was like that would be cannon on my
body that would be sick as hell like
that
that would be canon if it's on your body
it's canon you know
basically yeah i think i would love if
steve rogers got a back tattoo with that
with the same one it's like oh yeah uh
what a coincidence i i i'm not always
copying you it's just completely
coincidence no not yourself that's a
good rogue that's a good role question
is what would the other
like marvel heroes have tattooed on
their back yeah what are they what is
everyone else's backpack i love that one
keep in mind keep it right keep it noted
loki would have a [ __ ] stamp though he
really would and you know it
he so would 1000
and that leads us to our first topic of
today what's up with this new armor for
thor in valkyrie because why have four
and valkyrie upgraded into new armor and
helmets in this movie since the armor
looks like it might have been mapped
onto them in post-production could this
have been a decision made late in the
production phase or could this have been
triggered by jane's power-up what do you
guys think is going on here it's
interesting to consider that they did it
late like they didn't know from the
beginning what armor was going to look
like i mean some of it has to be
practical right there there are like
practical elements to it but yeah they
could change the color conceivably of
the armor and we would never even know
they're always doing like weird little
stuff like that
what if this is the armor that they're
getting from the gods um from zeus
it's very colorful like
yeah it's a little present i think
they're gonna go to olympus to like be
like hey gore's coming and to give them
a warning and also to try and insist on
them helping so why not them like start
being like okay well we got to get you
armored up that outfit is made of rags
and zeus like rips his clothes off puts
your clothes on
so yeah i think it's a gift it's a gift
from the gods yeah man maybe there's
just like a dress code at olympus and
you know there's it wasn't cutting it
you know you just didn't look fancy and
god like enough so they had to go naked
slap on a new costume now he's good to
go now he's going to write going off
what wendy said i absolutely could see
olympus being that like because olympus
and asgard just imagining those two like
ran by odin ran by zeus how do they run
each other and they probably like
literally have their noses high to
asgardians they're probably so mean to
asgardians they're probably like where
are the classy ones you guys are filthy
so they definitely have a dress code 100
for sure i think they're like sure
they're pretty much like rivals in the
comic books over the years like oh they
are in the asgardians like they don't
get along very well thor and thor and
hercules are always like uh rivals
rivalry in the comics it's always so fun
i want hercules to come in this so bad
because he's got him he's
hercules is a huge [ __ ] like in the
comics
everyone like everyone and i know that
everyone who's watching this is going to
be like who was also a huge [ __ ] in
greek mythology yeah i know that i'm
aware he's a [ __ ] no matter what and we
we support a whole face we really do i
want it i want it to
i love it i want him to be played by
henry cavill and i don't care that he's
superman i want henry cavill in the mcu
it's going to be a great choice liam
hemsworth all day liam's hemsworth
hercules all freaking day
liam isn't as big liam is not as big
that is like that he's a demigod though
he's a demigod
yeah but hercules is also big no this is
true
i don't want a little bit also i'm gonna
be watching this being like what are
they gonna kiss when are they gonna kiss
you can't think like that when it's two
brothers nah oh yeah but i can't when
it's henry cavill
that was me and uh top gun i said oh
they're gonna kiss now here's when they
kiss i was like oh they're gonna kiss
now they get killed
but no i i really like it
i really love this idea of zeus giving
for this armor because we've seen the
trailer that he does get disrobed so
and once jesus finds out he made a
mistake he's probably going to be like
oh my bad here's your here's your armor
that you need and like and we see from
like various other mcu entries with moon
knight being the latest example i feel
when steve grant opens up the
sarcophagus with uh alexander the great
we see like this weird blue and gold i
think it was an axe yeah yeah look at
the axe because he uses that in a fight
yeah i feel like like with um and with
with asgard and all that blue and gold
is seems to be the colors of the gods i
don't know what it is about blue and
gold but like that seems to be the the
trend and so like we see that thor has
this blue and gold armor it makes sense
to me that uh the people of olympus were
like all right here you go here's your
fancy new armor and uh you're good to go
my friend sorry about that are you gonna
sell lots of action figures with this
one i'll tell you what well but thor
thor's armor always comes from like the
lightning right he never like takes it
off right and sets it aside so it and it
always changes
you know through the magic of the
lightning or through the magic of asgard
right that his lighting changes and when
he when he gets like stormbreaker right
and like gets the lightning strike then
the armor is different it's like changed
i think the gold in his armor is from
zoo or is from
his own dad it's like the all father
magic
remember like uh odin's helmet had kind
of like that kind of like yeah he had
the sharp face covering and like
yeah i think he's kind of absorbed some
of odin's armor because there's no odin
right now like you have king valkyrie
yeah but i think she's usually like she
probably has all father magic but it's
different
but didn't they show her they showed her
armor off right didn't he like give her
a set of like valkyrie armor or she
pulled it out in ragnarok when she like
puts on the valkyrie armor
so hers exists like tangentially but
maybe now she has like magic armor too
like you definitely handed her a sword
and it looked like some straps or
something like that i still i still
i would love i love bran and siri that
it's odin's i still i'm banking on
because he's physically there zeus but i
understand for the storyline but i think
the storylines metaphor and undertones
are more so like you can still be a hero
without being a hero more than it's like
my dad who's dead i think that was a
thor ragnarok was about like was his
dad's message so i think this one will
be more like here's zeus is lightning
take control of it this is what you can
do with it yeah um because that could
also give way to why
uh valkyrie has a different outfit but
also she's whipping zeus's lightning
bolt in the trailer yeah maybe she's
getting it from the the zeus magic the
zeus match the fact that zeus is like a
single balkan daddy magic
russell crowe daddy
i don't mind zeus me and daddy but
russell crowe is my daddy daddy magic
well like grandpa you know what i'm
saying grandpappy magical boy magic
[Laughter]
the idea of like this being like
inherited armor from his father or like
some type of like passed down all father
type armor makes a ton of sense to me
because like you know like every person
on like odin's line of family had like
the special armor i mean like a boar i
believe had some like a special look and
like odin had a special look so i think
thor himself has yet to have his own
like inherited cool special look from
his father it'd be really cool to have
like a little gift from his dad wasn't
the eye patch from his dad
that was courtesy of hello
but he looked like his dad and she was
like
you know my first thing as soon as i saw
my brother after years was i cut his eye
out
i went to his house i went to his
bookstore and i said yeah
siblings it's what happens like every
every time elliot comes home for
christmas vacation i'm just like give me
that eye give it to me
they're standing over them
give me that let me sit down at the
table give me that eye no give it to me
first you pick up before i just pick up
a fork from the dinner table yeah
dinner table she's sitting there with
that fork at the end whitney put your
fork down
it's the same fork for all these years
yes it's a tradition it's a tradition
dude it truly is you know people that
don't have siblings don't understand
elliott if you're listening to this i'd
never stab you i'm sorry jeremy if
you're listening to this you i've
already stabbed you and i'll do it again
and you'll never find me
where's my dirty fork
do you think do you think korg's gonna
get like any armor
yeah
i wanna see that he's sitting there
right like next to them in the godly
chamber or whatever i don't think
they're gonna give it to him they'll
deputize them i'll make them unofficial
i'll give it to him if they won't if
they're not to give it to him i'll just
give it to him imagine if korg is worthy
to wield
like storm like about like
something
that's a good dude
i can see him being worthy
meek is still there right
yeah meek was like standing next to
valkyrie in one of the trailers so why
not also be
deputy well meek i like you i like me
more than four clearly i love a good
roach
i love the road i do love mia like i
feel like meek has the strongest quotes
in the mcu so far i think that every
time i read a meet quote i cry a little
bit uh because it it it touches me on a
personal level um
[Music]
me can't pick up
here because anyone who's got those like
knives for hands they're not this is
true they're not worthy they're
underhanded they're they're a little
just cut off one of the knight hands and
just to shove the mule near the other
one damn like evil dead like evil dead
yes like evil dead
dude i just thought about this but how
cute would it be
if there was a little tiny hammer like
this big for baby groot to pick up and
just be like i would love that didn't do
that did the frog thor did he have a
hammer in there or was he just jumping
he didn't have a yeah he had a little i
know i think he had a tiny hammer in the
dirt that he was trying to jump oh he's
trying to get to he was trying to get to
it yeah yeah
that would be so let's put a baby groot
in the in the void and like pick
skipping
rocket rocket doesn't have a hammer he
just picks up someone's prosthetic leg
and he's like
this is enough for me this is enough for
me
what do you think whitney i think did we
get your thoughts yet i i just agreed
with jess or i think it's going to be an
olympus and i like it
i agree with whitney so i think our
answer was like a tandem powers combined
yeah our powers combined who made the dr
divine
lose this rogue theory i'm going to take
a shot of this lotion so keep that in
mind
if i lose this
frequently for me to allow you to take
that back i am going to take a shot of
this this this
daily moisturizing
listen
you can't have ashy you cannot have an
ashy esophagus it's not no you can't let
me tell you guys make sure you drink the
lotion and you just
moisturize the hydrate your insides
exactly and believe it or not water
doesn't work for that who knew you got a
drink i need 70 of water not enough not
enough apparently um
let's all do the loach pie the the loach
pod challenge
she keeps biting me under the desk and
so i force her in my arms just ignore
her keep going but no this is
again as always all amazing answers but
i really particularly like brandon's
answer about like this being like
inherited all father's armor because
like i i really want to see thor and
like uh like some type of regal gear
because like he's he's sort of just like
like in the trailer you sort of just
bumming it out it's like i'm in my
ravager gear and i've sort of just
forgotten my asgard roots
after the whole uh ragnarok adventure
i'm sort of just like i'm sort of like
an earthling i feel like all the
asgardians have adopted towards like
this earth lifestyle of just like all
right jeans shirts like it's whatever so
yes i'm going to give brandon 20 000
rogue points for that oh because that's
pretty dang rogue i would not have
considered that at all it's a really
cool idea but also you ladies um with
your tandem team up i love this idea
please check it out no no i'm drinking
no
it sounds like i'm losing it sounds like
i'm not
no i'm going to give you guys 19 000
reports so it's only only 1 000 away so
it's still anyone's game really yeah
what 19 each because you guys are so
smart all of you um but yes
before jess might may or may not drink
the lotion we have a famous missing ass
guardian that is coming up um in this
movie that we haven't seen in a while
but first be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com to grab our latest
newest latest obsession shirt empire's
most wanted inspired by the release of
the new obi-wan kenobi series you ever
heard of it it's a pretty big deal you
should go watch it and when you purchase
this shirt you get a chance to unlock a
shout out that will appear on our weekly
wikileaks star wars show hosted by eric
voss and tommy bechtold two amazing men
and like all of our latest obsession
shirts once this shirt sells out it is
gone forever so do not miss out on an
opportunity to grab one before it's lost
forever to the sands of tatooine if you
hate sand it's not gonna be good for you
so check out all of our awesome merch
options it's rough irritating and it
gets everywhere
i love eating it it's my favorite rock
to digest
i was putting it in my sandwich it's
really good fiber
sandwich
so check out all of our new and awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and did you know
that new rockstar streams live every
weekday right here on youtube.com be
sure to check out the break room our
daily live show that covers the top nerd
nudes of the day streamed from our very
own break room at new rockstars hq it
streams every day at 3 p.m pacific so be
sure to check it out because we just
love talking about goofy stuff it's the
best and do not forget new rockstars is
also on tumblr.com i don't know if
you've heard about this it's tumblr.com
you can check out our official new
rockstars tumblr page curated by our
very own lovely jessica clements yes i
was gonna say if you don't say my name
i'm gonna be so mad
you guys are messaging me and i respond
and you're like jessica how are you not
gonna post stuff for pride month on
tumblr and i already have started we've
been talking about all the lgbtq plus
characters in the mcu and i will be
bringing more to you on tumblr because
what gayer platform for me to talk about
it on when i tell him
when i go to tumblr for my buy [ __ ] so
same that's where hot ladies are that's
where they can be found
if you're new to tumblr or are a current
tumblr user or someone who used to be on
tumblr but hasn't been in there in a
while be sure to stop by our official
new rockstars tumblr page today just
check it out because jess is amazing and
she posts the best stuff in the world um
but
let's let's move on to our next topic
because there is a certain character
from the first two thor films that we
have not seen in a while that leads us
to our second topic of today
where is lady siff like what happened to
her because she was she was great in the
first two thor films that she wasn't in
four three what happened
wasn't she i thought she
i thought they died
the warriors three died but she doesn't
die yeah but not she's she skipped it's
not there she's like so ella's coming
i'm gonna take a vacation yeah she's
just like this is actually the exact
time i chose to go to europe
so really quick i guess we we can as a
unit as a team can we break down when we
see so we saw lady siphon loki in the uh
but that's not even
right that's like a yeah that's like a
like a weird relationship
a simulation but she exists
she exists so that like that time loop
is still like existing of a character
that exists right so we're aware okay so
we saw our last layer and thor one and
two
and she was on the last asian official
shield as well she's agents of shield
that's where she was she was on agents
of shield because agents of shield came
out around thor the dark world and they
were doing a tie-in and it was like
agents of shields were dealing with the
aftermath of the convergence in london
well uh she has to she has to be like
i want her to be dead the only reason i
want her to be dead
is because
jesus
i did not expect that i just didn't
expect that i want her to be dead the
reason i want her to be dead is not only
because the warriors three died and she
just wasn't there for it and i feel like
she has to answer to that because how
are we gonna just
skim over that
secondly
i
don't think it's possible unless she's
hiding laying low this strong warrior
person literally in the comics one of
the craziest people
is just laying low in asgard this entire
time when asgard got ragnarok and then
the ship blew up on one portion they got
their [ __ ] ragnarok man yeah they got
they got ragnarok smacked so why are
molly
so
that's why i want her dead but she
clearly have we are she's in thor love
and thunder correct or no well her name
her name appears on the poster that they
put out oh yeah it's in the credits
whose name lady siff jamie alexander who
plays ladies yeah who plays seth steph
how do you guys think they're going to
explain her absence in thor 4 like
because she wasn't around in in 4-3
they've said like she was blipped away
too she was a uh someone who was blipped
so she was gone for like those five
years too and when i think i i read
there was an interview with like um
kevin feige back in the day
when when someone had asked like why
isn't lady sith in or ragnarok i think
they were doing it around the time of
thor ragnarok was like press interview
and he had said he had kind of
intimated that like it was a a
scheduling conflict for
the actress she was on a show at the
time right yeah
either on a show or maybe on broadway or
something she was like couldn't do it
and so he spun it as like well we don't
see her on ragnarok so she's pop
we don't see her on asgard during
ragnarok so she's probably fine so
that's a good thing he was basically
like it's good she wasn't there because
all the other ones died yeah it would
make sense that she would be like
following orders
whatever that means right she's a very
loyal person she's not gonna dip out
when there's a fight she's not gonna let
the other three die
if she could have done something but i i
think like odin before
because we have to imagine she took an
order from odin
but that could have been an odin that
was controlled by loki or loki
pretending to be odin and maybe he like
sent her away
like as true as as odin was like i need
you to go on this very long mission to
one of the other nine realms you're the
only one i trust just to get her out of
there so he didn't get got because he
knows the other three or idiots that is
it wouldn't figure out good that anyways
like loki so i bet loki just sent her on
like a wild goose chase that would take
a thousand years because she says
guardian right that makes sense
because like jessica wants her dead so i
don't know
unfortunately i have a disagreement with
you but also
do you really want to see me eat lotion
because it sounds like i don't know
for a man that really hates when i eat
things next to him you really made it
it's not my problem it's not my problem
but you can't think
um
the only reason okay so the only reason
i
disagree with what brandon is saying
which hey don't worry too much into it
is in the comics loki did fool sif a lot
or especially when that that part that
we saw in loki was real in the comics of
him messing with her so bad
yeah it cut her hair so it's like
pull me one shame on you you know like i
think she would know not to follow loki
again she does not like loki okay so
that's the only reason why i'm like i
don't think she'd follow loki or listen
to loki because she doesn't like loki
you think loki is odin yeah no like he's
like in the beginning of thor ragnarok
he was posing as odin oh yeah he was
posing as odin oh
and center on a request oh
he was like i need you to go to
blue heim
i need you to go to the grocery store
yeah on another planet because like i
feel like because he's been like because
he's spent centuries playing pranks on
sif siff would probably smell loki out
immediately yeah right she's just
because
she's like been like the number one
the number one like victim of his prank
so like she would be like you're not
odin you're loki you idiot so loki was
like go away i don't want to see you
anymore go on a mission go go find some
grapes i don't know
go find some grapes if he does it in
front of everybody like
odin odin loki like calls all of asgard
out for this big ceremony he's like i'm
gonna give you a medal and she's like
okay he's like here's your meadow also i
need you to go do this and he says in
front of everybody then like even if you
know that's loki all of asgard thinks
odin just told you to go do something so
you have to go do it right you'd have to
right yeah it's probably like an
impossible task it's like all right go
uh i don't know
uh bring the moon to me and then she
asked herself she's out on this weird
task she gets blipped comes back and
probably like what the hell was that
does anyone know anyone around here now
no no one has no idea
what happened she comes back to asgard
like what the [ __ ]
she pulls up in her car she's like what
the where did that where's
it ella's just like floating around in
space yeah she would hear that her
entire place was blown up she wouldn't
even know where to go
that's probably she's probably gonna
roll back up in the nuanced garden be
like what the [ __ ] is going on guys did
anyone call me
do we is she related to heimdall have we
like oh
i thought
i don't know in the comics they're
brother and sister but i don't know
in the mcu he doesn't talk about family
period so i guess he could straight up
be like yeah or she could be like my
brother
and we're like
he's dead
he murdered so about that about that
weird theory about heimdall i think
heimdall actually belongs to the
sovereign and uh oh i would love that
upgraded his being and so like he's just
like the what a sovereign should look
like if they didn't upgrade themselves
because the sovereign have orange eyes
it can potentially and
for some reason could see within peter
quill's genealogy with just their
eyeballs so i think that their eyeballs
are super good at seeing [ __ ] um i mean
they couldn't see rockets still in those
batteries though
idiots yeah but yeah
that's just my weird favorite but yes
very good idea what what do you think
whitney
um i don't know so what i'm gonna say is
that
ladies if
uh got asked to go on a podcast
and unfortunately what happened was is
that she lost
and so she ended up
taking a huge mouthful of lotion
this is true i heard that as well it
sounds familiar this sounds very
familiar she's been hospitalized on
another world because that doesn't sound
familiar i lost a podcast and she ate
some lotion and now she's coming back
and she's like hey guys my tummy feels
better i'm ready to fight
this is weird because that story sounds
so familiar but i remember her getting
stronger from eating the lotion she
didn't go to the hospital
she got much stronger for me i think
it's a
i think that mistranslation in the
comics she got stronger which she did
yeah i think this is actually erskin's
formula uh jergens which is that was a
that was a different universe that was
an offshoot
that was the oh that's the universe
where they have
a cure for lotion eaters yeah yeah yes
it's the what if lotion universe yeah
that's that's in the multiverse where
everyone eats lotion they eat lotion and
they put pizza on their hands lotion
papa always gets pancakes lotion papa
always
[Music]
immediately lotion mama can come over
anytime i like the podcast idea though
there's got to be at least one asgardian
living on earth with a podcast right
there's gotta be sky dude everyone has a
podcast if you're over 30 and you don't
have a podcast what are you doing yeah
even uh
j jonah jameson has a podcast
technically yeah exactly he likes
james has a podcast if anyone does there
you go i think they all do but no these
are all again really interesting ideas
really great theories um i i think
myself personally i think that lady siff
could potentially have gone to fight
gore like maybe that's why she was gone
because like she knew something was cool
yeah like because like in in 4-3 we find
out that like for some reason
odin has been like odin's life was
connected to
uh hello's imprisonment and so as soon
as odin died hell was like i'm back into
the land of light and i think that odin
imprisoned a lot more people than just
hella and i think that gore the god
butcher was probably one of those people
and i think it'd be really fun if like
she was the first person to confront
gore that we see in the movie anyway and
just be like hey you're not going
anywhere and uh gore unfortunately kills
her because i feel like
i feel like there's this weird marvel
studios plan that all the warriors three
and like all the people of asgard had to
die at some point and like well that's
ragnarok dog that's ragnarok dog
yeah it's a ragged rock and i feel like
has to die
[Laughter]
a theory
i think this isn't even like a hardcore
theory i'm just going off of what
brandon said because i was like i like
the idea that he is performing as odin
so if we did stick to the older comics i
think it'd be fun to keep that story
line of like odin
loki as odin was like there's this girl
named jane foster and i need to know
that she's worthy again go fight her
again
and so she had to go and find jane
foster who's a nice freaking girl who
they they're like we actually get along
very well and she helps her train
she helps her back
[Music]
because i think that way when thor runs
into her he also runs into sif and sif's
like i'm over you i literally am just
team team mighty thor like i'm team jane
foster
girlfriends unite you know like
ex-girlfriends should always unite
actually my best friend and i are best
friends because we both dated the same
[ __ ] and then in the aftermath she
texted me and i was like i didn't know
you exist and she was like oh i knew you
existed and i hate you and then now
we're best friends and it's amazing
hey
there you go lifestyle
i just think [ __ ] bring people
together you know they really do
i like the metaphor and the physical of
[ __ ] being together
yeah
good times
let's pucker up our [ __ ]
again these are all great theories but
again brandon i really love this idea of
like loki odin sending her away because
like she's just super smart this knows
loki's trickery a lot because she's
spent centuries being a victim of it so
i feel like it would make sense for loki
just to be like all right go away i
don't want you to find me out just go
off into the other side of the universe
and like you know just i don't want to
be caught which is why loki like thor
found out it was lucky in two seconds so
i was like yeah sif would definitely be
on that same train so i'm going to give
you another 20 000 points because you're
a smart man
yo your brain is worth 20 thousand rogue
points apparently before that's how much
your brain is worth my doctor please yes
i really i also really love this idea of
jaden sift training together because sif
is one of the most badass fighters in
the universe and i can't see anybody
else um being fit to train jane foster
thor so i'm going to give you again 19
000 rogue points jess for that one and
i'm going to give you 15 000 for the
lotion whitney because it's quite funny
i wasn't expecting to win i just wanted
to make you guys think for a minute make
me exactly don't drink the lotion or
else your tummy will don't drink it
and jess
or you'll be the strongest person in
your cul-de-sac so how about you do
drinks
make sure it's a vino though not jergens
or some other yes
not the disgusting flavors get the good
flavor vino
i can't believe that they named the
lotion jurgens because it just sounds
too much like something you
intentionally jerk off with
like you know just
you know just jerking off you know
me
that poor man he's trying to drag it on
for when you're jerking off oh my god
anyway
you got to put the dragon i worked on
slogans for jergens for several months
before i was fired um
for months
it could have killed me it's gonna fool
me actually they fired me in the first
week but i just kept coming in just kept
coming in just kept clocking in
kept clocking into jerk awesome
free jergens can't pass this up but this
leads us to our rogue question of the
day because if new asgard is the
official four theme park which mcu or dc
hero or villain would you like to have a
whole theme park based around that you
would go visit that's a good question
i'll tell you which one i wouldn't want
the answer is frog man i say frog man
frog man a theme park would be so boring
and stink
he would snake and be born
i think you gotta do
i'm a child
of the 80s and grew up with honey i
shrunk the kids which was
like
a dream paradise riding a man eating a
giant oatmeal cookie sandwich oh you
mean just go to pim kitchen you mean
kitchen brandon no
listen jessica i want a whole theme park
basically a whole park you get shrunk
down
but you get to do all this cool stuff
and a tiny park and the food is huge and
you get to like ride ants uh yeah i
think like ant-man theme park would be
great plus it would have a very low
carbon impact on the environment you
don't need a big you could put one in
every city you know everybody gets
stepped on immediately by accident oh
there's a protective bubble jessica
there's a protective i'm just saying i
think that's a bad idea up on a table
they put the theme park up on a table
read it you're not thinking about it
you're not thinking they're not thinking
up on a table on a table
i'll eat them on purpose
i'll show up
but i would love an ant-man themed theme
park because like everything would just
be big and just funny and like like you
said all the food would be gigantic like
imagine having like a giant ass burger
would just be hilarious like i'm eating
a regular sized burger but i'm an ant
person it'd just be funny uh but i love
that idea it's very smart very fun what
do you ladies think
um well i'm gonna not go with
marvel or dc because i think it would be
really fun to have a scott pilgrim world
um yes yeah and like have it like every
time you move or do anything you get the
little comic like
signs you know like that and then
there's really no music playing in the
park they have like really cool live
shows every night
a much better idea than brandon i love
that that is right
another rule of the theme park is that
if you and your evil ex show up at the
theme park at the same time you have to
battle to see which person gets to stay
i like this
so you have to take out your evil ex if
you want to be able to go on rides
yes
or if you show up to the door with your
evil ex and uh you guys fight the person
that wins gets to go in for free oh gets
to go in for free yeah other person has
to pay
also
has to call their own ambulance it would
be great if like the biggest baddest
roller coaster was called clash of demon
head because that would just be a sick
name for a roller coaster like a really
intense roller coaster called clash of
demonic that'd be just the best i'd be
selling i would love a roller coaster
based off of that moment where um what's
his face chris evans is grinding on the
rails yes
oh yeah so to go since we're just this
is improv and we're hitting higher and
higher beats
um i don't want
i wanted it
and inside out uh type of like superhero
[ __ ] so i want you to show up to this
theme park and you don't get batman you
get a man bat i don't want you to get
black widow i want you to see a widow in
black i don't want you to see hawkeye
you get an eye of a hawk i want
everything in burst and i want it to be
realistic bizarro
yeah yeah yeah i want bizarro yeah
bizarro world so i want like catwoman
but it's just a woman that's dressed
like a cat and goats around
it's just judy dench from cats yeah yeah
she's like
with her wedding ring still on and she's
like hello yeah
cause the fun would also be from you
guessing what it is you'd be like yeah
it would what is this what is this
yeah
man super
man super
and you protect yourself from lawsuits
because you're not actually using the
characters
do you know who woman wonder is yeah
she's based it's basically ruth bader
ginsburg so it's just like it's aoc aoc
shows up and you're like which could she
be and it's woman wonder so
yeah
educational and beautiful
i love it i dig it it's really extra
rogue but yes
all these are super super rogue answers
i love you guys so much you guys are
amazing um i think i'm going to have to
give the most rogue points here to
jessica clemens because uh that inside
out world opposite direction
opposite town looks like this lotion
isn't going in my mouth today but no i
really love jess's idea of this inside
out theme park it'd be super fun and
lawsuit free so i'm gonna give jess 50
000 rogue points for that one extra
rogue but i really extra love
brandon's ant-man theme park i really i
think it's a really fun idea having like
a whole pim aspect i just love when like
you know ant-man shrinks and
everything's just really big and i would
love if they just made a whole freaking
theme park of just big [ __ ] um so i'm
going to give brandon
don't give me a lot of points i can't
say jessica you can you can see you can
see things that are bigger than you at
pim kitchen and disney in disneyland
california adventure surprisingly i'm
going to give brandon
30 000 points for that one because it
was pretty good um yes i'm gonna give
whitney 40 000 points for her scott
pilgrim world because i think it's a
really amazing idea i love scott pilgrim
it's the best and like i really just
want to see more so yes scott pilgrim
world gets 40 which makes jess i suggest
jessica is the winner yes yes our winner
of the day lotion will not be eaten this
day
no lotion today you guys i wanted to be
known that every time i win rogue theory
it's because i threatened something
horrible before this show it's true
i win a lot it's usually because
i'm very competitive at any game do not
play with me at any board games or in
life because i will threaten don't play
do not play with jess period
that's probably why it's good though
that we're both on this podcast because
i'm the one who's like i don't care if i
win
i'm just gonna say
the points don't really matter it's all
just having fun with each other and just
you know just being goofy and being an
extrovert mine is it anyway i mean
that's the real thing isn't actually
anyway anyway um but that is it for this
rogue theory episode thank you to our
amazing guests jessica clemons whitney
van laningham and of course off-screen
producer brandon support all of their
stuff on twitter follow them on twitter
they're amazing and support our channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and hey if you've got thoughts on our
latest rogue theory episode you can
share them on our discord just click the
link in the description to join that
today and again you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you wanna
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] but more
importantly following the rockstars
wherever we are on social media and be
sure to subscribe on our channel here on
youtube we love you guys so much so
freaking much thank you guys for
spending time with us and we'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you